thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
what's going on guys gaming out here
coming at you for another uh
man I can't believe I almost did that I
almost gave
the
the what I would normally do for the
Paul uh for my personal Channel man I
it's been it's been a rough week man
it's been a rough month for Xbox one
would say so
what's going on guys Lord addict here
coming at you with another attic show
where we talk about the past present and
future uh today mainly about Xbox I got
here with my co-host Got Dirt griggity
what's been going on there
oh man
listen attic
I've seen
ponies I haven't seen on my channel in
years
they popped uh they popped up today
I've seen guys that that never leave
comments
leaving comments today
oh
it's been a crazy day bro it's going on
yeah the dirt had like that moment where
he was like meet me outside catch me
outside how about that
so crazy we got a pretty good show for
you guys today we're going to talk about
actually let me move this over a little
bit
see I don't have to uh I got like a new
little thing I do for for my podcasts
and stuff but I don't have to do that
for here all right so we got a pretty
big show for you guys we're going to
talk about Activision deal being blocked
obviously well it's not it's been
blocked by one of my part yeah
um then we got high five rush you know
got the whole stuff that's transpired
since last week and then we also got the
lack of PlayStation exclusive events and
you know because I had to put a little
bit there's a little little bit there's
a lot of Xbox negative stuff going on so
I had to balance the force all right man
we had too much Vader not enough Luke
so I had to balance it
we gotta find out super chat from
Nintendo Donna Taco I speak for everyone
when I say where's the t uh uh tears of
the Kingdom topic don't steer you're
talking about the actual important
topics because he's a bot
we talk about
oh I did promise people didn't I I think
I did
I promise people that
I don't know I mean we could talk about
it like let's see unlike I take
criticism
all right we could talk about breath of
the wild I'm not putting it in the topic
titles but we could talk about it
what you've been playing
Dead Island too brother told you last
week it was good didn't I love it
I listen I love better than the original
Dead Island I like it better than the
Dying Light one and two I love it bro
I'm enjoying I was playing it right
before the podcast started yeah I I
personally feel like dying light's a
better franchise
um so I think that's what's going on
here is I like Dying Light because I
feel like there's more movement I feel
like you know in a zombie apocalypse
when I come across a gate
that Gate's not gonna prevent me from
jumping that thing I jump it now when
I'm a grown ass adult why wouldn't I
jump that if it was a zombie apocalypse
so yeah I appreciate it I I understand
that so uh we do have a patreon question
uh it was pretty interesting uh let's go
ahead and talk about that real quick
all right for those of you that don't
know too is uh me and King I don't know
if the anime fans in here I know there's
a few of them but for the anime fans we
actually just recorded the episode
reveals about the armored and The
Colossal type it's in season two so I'm
sure people I'm not going to say
anything more than that because they'll
spoil it but I'm sure you guys know what
I'm talking about by saying that me King
just reacted to it it's not up on the
patreon yet but I think you guys will
enjoy it once it's up for the for the
people that like that if people don't
like anime reaction stuff like that TV
uh you know
you can always pop up on there I think
I'm going to do some uh some fun stuff
on there too for because I realize I am
appealing to a lot of the uh p uh to the
anime community and stuff I need to do a
job appealing toad just Ryan to uh you
know the people that follow the content
like Gamers and stuff all right so we
got a question from Benjamin what's it
going to take for companies to 86 this
trend of releasing their products below
expectation with no reservation uh
reservation I don't know I probably
butchered that how do we get the
industry to appreciate patience and
efficiency again
thanks guys love your work so I think
he's pretty much saying look there's too
many companies releasing bugging
products uh in your personal opinion
dark what would it take for them to stop
doing that
the customer stopped buying them
yeah I think yeah I think
first off we're never going to do that
you know if you're excited for something
you're gonna buy it I think it's going
to take more stuff
like the um the cyberpunk situation
if that happens a couple of times and
these companies get severely punished
for having broken games at launch I
think that will do more than anything
else would
uh it's got to be punishment for if a
company is worried they're going to get
thrown off of um of all these platforms
just by having a buggy game they'll be
very more cautious because it's not the
potential of losing money it's the
potential of not making it because
they're going to spend that if they if
they got to the point where if a
developer knew for a fact a publisher no
because developers would fix it for the
most part but if a publisher knew for a
fact that putting your game busted on a
platform is going to get a de-listed and
the only way to get unlisted is to um
until the game is fixed a lot of
developers would be like very cautious
okay
we don't want to get de-listed because
if you could do listed it's probably
going to look bad in general yeah so I
think it's going to take more scenarios
like that but you know I definitely
appreciate the question Benjamin uh
anyone else that wants to get into the
question thing here's the patreon sign
up for the patreon you get access to
asking any of the the shows we have
questions uh once a week you also get
access to reactions that me king and
solve and call do we're going to start
making Cog react to White music that's
what he calls it white people music he
he's gonna react to some heavy metal and
that's going to be interesting uh and
then you know King's been react to
attack on Titan I just finished reacting
to chainsaw man so that's in the comment
section there definitely go over there
and follow that so let's get into this
let's get into it man first off let's
talk about the lack of PlayStation
offense I think we can agree that that's
happening would you not agree
yeah of course yeah I think we can agree
that that's happening the question is
why do you think it's happening and do
you think it's bad or do you think that
you know there's just stuff going on
that we don't know
well I think it's just you know I don't
think enough teams had stuff ready to
show uh I do believe they'll have one
this year probably next month I really
do believe that um I just feel that they
just you know they're like look man
we're in the lead no biggie we'll show
stuff when we're ready to show stuff
that's it I mean I just think that the
teams just didn't have enough already
to show you know um because you think
about their Studios you know God of what
writing Rogers came out
Horizon from being West just came out
you know of course they're they're
probably ready to show Spider-Man 2
since it's coming out this year
maybe last year Wolverine wasn't ready
to be shown yet so you know they have
some things they they just wasn't ready
to show you but I do think they will
have one this year because I do think
they're they're ready to show some
factions
um you know some some uh like Silent
Hill some third party exclusives that
they have metal gear maybe so I I do
think they're ready to show something
now but you know it is what it is
yeah I will tell you this all the years
the Xbox never had no games they always
had the E3
I I think
just not showing stuff is a bit is a big
issue and the reason I think that
is because
us as Gamers we we kind of have like a
life set at this point
we expect E3 we expect the Video Game
Awards at the end of the year
we expect uh you know fall releases the
bigger games in the fall we expect Call
of Duty at the end of the year
we really do have every year a set path
that we expect
and the fact that Sony has just withdrew
from it entirely
hmm
definitely makes you feel nervous a
little bit now I'm not going to say it's
like the end of the world but I I wish
that you know they they would care about
their fans because they didn't know that
that's what this is like you know
they don't have to do any of these
events but their fans want these events
and I feel like they've been very
lackluster when it comes to any type of
event for future projects that's why
people have been so on to them it's like
look like you know we know that
Spider-Man's coming out this year but
besides that like Ronan what else
nothing you can't really think of
anything besides maybe Final Fantasy
part two
I think a lot of that has to do with the
the Activision deal
I think that they don't want to look too
strong I think I've said this multiple
times on the show I think now that this
deal is starting to wind down which
we'll get into here in a little bit
you'll start seeing more from them you I
think they'll do more state of plays
because if you notice that the only
thing that they ever really do is stuff
we already know stay to play on Final
Fantasy 16 state of play on this it's
it's stuff that we know because I think
both
companies Microsoft and Xbox are very
concerned on making the narrative
they're trying to push on social media
and try to push in courtrooms they're
they're too obsessed with making sure
that that is what they're doing
5 41.
yeah so I think I think that's what's
going on here I do
yeah um like you said the ABK deal is
winding down well maybe or it might have
to go another two or three years
if it goes another two three years they
need to just stop trying to to fight it
and just let the court system do their
thing because at this point man I can't
handle another two or three years I can
bro I can't it's you know it's been a
long year but back to the topic uh you
know I understand what you're saying but
I just think about
um
I just think they needed a year I really
think they needed a year not to have a
showcase
I think this year they will have a
showcase like I said there are some
games they just that just wasn't ready
to be shown off last year some of those
games will be ready to be shown off this
year you know it was their first party
like a lot of them dropped games
recently
so a lot of them they weren't like ready
to show game so yeah we'll see what
happens yeah and what's funny is like I
get so annoyed when people act like
PlayStation wasn't affected by the
pandemic
oh you know this this they've they've
released games steadily no they haven't
they they've delayed probably more games
than Xbox They delayed
um returnal they delayed Last of Us They
delayed uh God of War God of War I think
they delayed Horizon didn't they yes
they delayed they've literally and
granted seven yeah so they've literally
delayed every 4
what happened here is they just had more
games further in development
yeah and because that not that now
you're seeing that with Microsoft they
those games are starting to come out and
they're getting delayed into this year
and you're seeing Microsoft have like a
game almost every month look Minecraft
Legends redfall Starfield you know they
have a lot of uh smaller exclusive
titles like these games are coming out
what regardless feel about them or not
feel about them they're still coming out
now it could be debatable on the quality
of the games but you can't debate on how
many is coming out
agreed
yeah so um you know what what is your
opinion on the PlayStation thing do you
think they need these events yeah of
course of course I mean listen man
they're the market leader they're doing
well but I'm sure these PlayStation fans
they they want to see what's what's
popping in the future I mean that's just
normal you know of course they want to
see uh Spider-Man or they want to see
some of factions they want to see what
is um you know Sucker Punch next game
what is Sony Santa Monica next game even
though that's probably further along but
yeah of course you know what's only been
next game
I'm sure they want to see all that I
feel like at this point the biggest
thing that we need is we just need games
and that's for Microsoft and Xbox
Microsoft and Sony we we need more of
these games popping out because I've
just gotten to the point where I'm just
so sick and tired of we just have
nothing to talk about games related you
know we haven't heard nothing about
Fable we haven't heard nothing about
ghost Shima too you think about it
Spider-Man is supposed to come out this
year and we still don't have any
gameplay on it right
that's not like the industry you know
even if you look at a redfall we've seen
a good amount of gameplay
um but most of the time we see more than
what we've seen
so it's it's just an interesting set of
things going on and I'm just I'm just
curious curious when the industry starts
going back to normal and we're actually
going to get information and get stuff
that we actually want because I would
say for the most part
the industry is in a downward spiral
right now that's everybody I would say
PlayStation's making good games but
people be acting like they're making
amazing games no they're not you know
but I think they're making better games
than Xbox but I don't think they're
making games that people throw out with
the kind of energy that people throw
all right so let me get this Super Chat
we're going to move on to high five Rush
Fiasco because there's a lot to talk
about there too yeah it is
all right so we got two all super trap
from
oh my God you guys want to showcase just
to call the games trash no I don't think
anyone's ever really said that no you
already didn't say that so we got 20
minutes and we'll say 25 seconds so
we're talking about Hi-Fi Rush
and let me tell you something if
PlayStation has a good show I would say
they had a good show
no I know I'm about and all that but if
they have a good show I would let it be
they had a good show I still feel the
show they had the second in September
2020 was a phenomenal show actually I
think that's the last showcase they had
for showcase
it was overshadowed by the we believe in
Generation stuff but the show itself was
fire I would say when PlayStation has a
great show man I'm not that type of Bot
to just blast bash everything
PlayStation no
and what's funny dirt is people will sit
there they'll take Snippets of a podcast
they'll sit there and like call Xbox
people like drones and stuff but
for the most part Xbox people do talk
about Xbox
but when it comes to these PlayStation
erraticates like
they only talk about Xbox
like go go to like
a PlayStation podcast or anything like
that and like look at the topics every
week
it's something to do with Xbox like very
rarely is it anything to do with
PlayStation almost exclusively
PlayStation channels and Playstation
podcasts are talking about Xbox uh now I
don't agree with the content they put
out sometimes the one of the only
exceptions I know is like Jabari and
Persona they're very messy but they do
try to put that aside to a point when
they do their what's up PlayStation
podcast but for the most part that's the
only podcast I know that Weekly we on
the weekend and week out they're talking
only about PlayStation for the most part
most of the time with these PlayStation
people and you know what I'm talking
about dirt they you could be talking
about anything you could be talking
about accessories you know that the the
elite controller needs to be replaced or
the the Dual sense controls batteries
broken and then somehow the conversation
ends up in all these different ways and
somehow we're talking about the quality
of games on Xbox
and we're not even talking about that
yeah and it's just it's so frustrating
sometimes because
you're trying to make content and you
see all these people being very very
messy putting people's pictures on
thumbnails and talking about other
people on channels to like a large
degree it's one thing to talk at like a
response video if someone's deliberately
saying you it's another thing to base
your whole channel on it and they're
being so successful on the terms that
you would see that channel be successful
on but then when you actually try to
make content on games
that not the Right audience that they
don't care because the majority of this
community does not care about games they
care about talking about games they care
about the entertainment that's brought
to their life by clowning on games and
gaming consoles they don't care about
the actual playing games part
yeah I mean like oh okay I um as a
channel that does console war stuff I
talk about
PlayStation I talk about Xbox or talk
about PlayStation Fanboys a lot and
you're right um
but I understand what my channel is I
understand what happens
um
my audience seems to like certain stuff
so you're right so when people when we
talk about games because I talked about
like E3 a few weeks ago you know the
video didn't do well because people I
know how Dirt talks them talk some [__]
about PlayStation family you know so it
is what it is but
I agree what you're saying though um
there's a very few yeah and see there's
a difference like you might talk about
console war stuff but it's it's in fun
like you could tell that yes and farmer
you could tell that like this is the
moment you turn off that camera and you
turn off that PC you might giggle or
laugh when you're reading something on
Twitter but it doesn't live in you it
does it's not your life I really be
thinking the way some of these people be
talking on YouTube it's their life
disappeared tomorrow they would be done
yeah unfortunately that's that's the
case I I do have fun with it now I am a
real Xbox fan but I do have fun with it
man
um you know you know so something like
it's a lot of guys in this chat like
dark times Knicks if they came with my
my channel they'll be blocked
immediately but you know it's all it's
all the fun with me man you know it's
all fun man
project more Oh I thought what's funny
is um I am working on uh because uh I do
have I do do contracts for like uh q a
and stuff
and he said project more and I was
reading an NDA that said project
something else and I'm like did I leave
something on my computer like oh it was
funny man it was funny so let's
let's actually get on to the Hi-Fi Rush
thing
um you know right now we have stuff
going on
stop
oh hold up my computer my camera
there we go right now we have stuff
going on where it is
Hi-Fi Rush Jeff grob he came out there
and he said yo you know he doesn't think
that
the higher end part of
Xbox kadim's Hi-Fi Russia success
um so you know first off I want your
general idea of what you think on this
well first I want to say that um Jeff
Grubb is very credible
I've always said that he has tons I mean
like gotten tons things right
um he's he's very credible and um so
when this came out you know when Jeff go
up speaks we got to listen to what he
says
because you never know you know
um I listen to what he said because he
is credible you know like he's a
credible source so I listen
and I said well I was kind of confused
at first added because I was like well
damn
didn't they say it was successful it
also was spoken on Steam the Xbox was
happy with it but there's the Tango
Gameworks is happy with I was kind of
confused
by you know what happened and what he
said
but then we see that uh immediately
after his story kind of went everywhere
and and Greenberg and those guys woke up
on the west coast they woke up and it's
gonna Aaron Greenberg immediately
tweeted what he uh said you know said
um I forgot the words he used but it you
know it was successful for XBox and and
their engagement numbers or whatever he
said then I saw Phil Spencer retweeted
it
so as a fan of Xbox that follows them
very closely in the past if there's
something that's true if there's a rumor
that's true or Xbox don't want to talk
about it they don't say much nothing
like mostly like they don't say a word
so for them to come out immediately
and say yo this isn't true Hi-Fi Rush
was a success for us and blah blah blah
I don't know
this seems to be like maybe Jeff grew up
her or something
maybe it can be true but he did say
fairly I don't know how Xbox measures
their success because this game was a
shadow drop it's in Game Pass so he's
not sure how they measure success
so I don't know man but it was crazy
I think the issue we're having here is I
do feel like there are people saying
that in the building but I don't think
they're from Xbox I think they're on
Microsoft's portion people have no
knowledge about what's going on on Xbox
they don't know the road map they they
don't know the business plan for the
most part you know you know maybe people
in finances that see you know uh this
this studio took this amount of money in
but they didn't bring this in
and maybe they're saying that uh but
it's like I said in a video that I made
like
Tango Ting Ting work Studio or uh
rectangle Game Works Tango Game Works
they
they increase the budget for them
they gave them more money they uh money
to hire people to me you don't reward
bad performance with money right it
makes no sense
and no realm does that happen
but I feel like there's a lot of people
that try to get this narrative just
because Jeff Grubb said that there's a
there's a possibility that Jeff Grubb
Source was right and wrong at the same
time he was right because people at that
in that little field think that but
they're wrong because they don't know
what's going on
remember when Phil Spencer said in in
the interview with
uh with Ryan McCaffrey when Ryan had all
the the leads of Xbox and he said I used
to go into meetings with people on
Windows and they're saying why are you
costing us so much money
um you know it's it's like an instance
for that it's like where these people
didn't know what's going on they didn't
know the world map they're only going
off base numbers yeah you know it could
be that you know high five Rush didn't
bring in the money that you it was used
to fund it
um at the end of the day
if they're funding money into Tango
how is it that a possibility
because why if you didn't make the money
you need to to recover from it why would
you pour more money into the brand it
makes no sense
absolutely um you know like a lot of
people brought up including myself we
brought up for spoken that game flopped
so bad that they disbanded the studio
told them yeah you know what no one
luminous production let's go back to
right that didn't happen so
they added they're adding additional um
employees so
if a game truly flopped that bad I mean
found a high additional employees
imagine it's that bad too
because I said this on IOP like you're
talking to someone and you're like yo
I want to I want you to come work for me
you're like but your game failed oh go
over there and work it don't matter like
what who would go over there right and
you know I get it this is what happens
when you don't give out solid numbers
and I don't think no one's ever really
going to
um to say that's not the case but at the
same time it's like dude
why are we always going off of what
other people say it's one thing to take
in one ear give it your own
kind of you know your own mindset okay
let me judge this off of what I know but
people be acting like they know more
than Jeff Grubb look Jeff Grubb has
messed up some
it's got something's wrong they don't
realize that when it comes to what Jeff
dot Jeff crop does which you know
Insider quote quote unquote
how do you become an Insider Dart
you have sources you know people that
know insiders is just glorified
middlemen
and sometimes the people that's talking
to you are wrong I'm sure that Jeff
Groff has so much information because I
get told stuff
and there's some people that say I don't
care if you tell this and there's some
people that's like yo keep this close to
the chest I don't want this out
I'm sure he's got a lot of stuff that he
can just leak like leak leak right only
time insiders normally leak stuff is
when they feel like another Insider is
gonna need one yeah anyone to be first
yeah that's true
it's only time man uh Jeff Grubb love
God to death
um I I've known for a fact I've been
told I've been in Xbox Live parties
where we're talking about a game or
something or something unannounced
and then oh dude Jeff Groves about to
leak that and the person that it will be
with another Insider and they will leave
yo I gotta I gotta go I gotta go do this
like like Jeff craw about to leak I got
at least be second or maybe beat him to
it right so it's just it's just how the
industry is and I get it people get
upset over it
um you know what I find hilarious is
people that have more uh they try to sit
on the more High Ground talking about
leaks in general it's like oh you know
this will ruin all these people all
these developers uh you know all this
work
I get it
it sucks
to not get that full-blown
moment that you put all this work into a
brand or a product and you get to show
it to the world for the first time
without a being leaked I'm sure that's a
special thing
but who do you think we should put the
blame on dirt
the person leaking or the person
breaking NDA giving leaks to the person
leaking the person bringing NDA because
they now for some reason people like
Tom Henderson and Jeff grogg and Jazz
Corden there's the one that get the the
Heat
it's like dude that's not their fault
that is literally their job is to give
you the information people give them
that's why people pay them money and you
expect them not to do their job
yep and you know Jeff Grove and you know
Tom Henderson and and Jess Gordon like
keep keep doing that man oh y'all put
Jason schreier in that too you guys make
my job easier covering the content
because it's easier to talk about
something when it's known yep I agree we
got a 20 Super Chat from face if you're
an Xbox fan I would stay off Twitter
today yeah I definitely agree on that
one I was on Twitter but my timeline is
so clean of ponies that I was okay
yeah he he he he he walks a straight
line because there ain't no one to jump
in front of yeah two dollars from Jeff
from nut on chin oh my God that's on
chin PlayStation fans just want Xbox to
be better there are some but for the
most part they don't care most of them
don't yeah most of them don't care the
only thing they care about something
engagement they can get on Twitter
that's all they care about you know
I will say there are people like
Dreamcast guy that go a little too extra
but I don't think Dreamcast got
sincerely wants Xbox to fail I do think
he wants them to improve but I think he
pushes his Persona a little bit because
he knows it's going to give views but
there are people
that claim they want the brand to do
better that I know damn well they don't
they hate Xbox I know people that's hate
Xbox they wanted to fail
then we got a fight off shooter from
bone slave uh this success gauges I'm
gonna be honest with customer
satisfaction so they hire more people to
make a bigger game and the same quality
Hi-Fi uh high five was well received it
was a great game and I think for the
most part everyone can agree that Hi-Fi
Rush was a huge success maybe you know a
hundred percent not in the the Xbox
scene like in terms of finances
but it's a seed and what I want to say
is a seed HiFi Rush is a seed that you
can grow into a big ass tree in the
future
uh it's a small project but guess what
they've they they're pouring more money
into Tango and if I'm willing to bet
dirt it's into the Hi-Fi Rush IP
okay
you got to find out super from Carl
Andrews Jr if that's your real names
Carl you need to probably change that to
something else don't ever have your real
name up on this stuff uh I remember a
music executive say that music is going
more digital it's about streaming not
about album sales could Xbox be thick in
the same way I do think that's the
thought process but I don't think that
the music industry in the gaming
Industries is Apples to Apples I think
there's a lot of differences that make
them different and I don't think what
you can do in the music industry is
going to mirror exactly what you can do
in the gaming industry I do think
there's similarities but I think there's
a lot of differences that's in the
industries uh two dollar shares from
from mid uh
looks like another one of my relatives
Super Chat oh my God I think he's
talking about nuts on chin
these people be crazy man yeah they are
right but I love it
it's funny sometimes they'd be a little
bit too much but it it'd be funny it'd
be funny all right let's
let's bring one of these question marks
uh because I you know what I I promised
Donna taco and I'm a man of my word
let's bring one of these question marks
let's talk about Zelda let's talk about
um first thing I want to ask you is are
you even going to buy Zelda no I don't
have a switch
I never played a Zelda game bro
all right so tell me
what doesn't appeal to you
honestly I think um no
no no
disrespect to Donna Taco you know the
gaming game before take all of the
Nintendo homies that Nintendo was really
awesome when I was a kid
even though I was a Sega God like kind
of like Cognito I was a Sega guy
everybody in my hood had Nintendo's I
was only a kid with the second Master
System
Mario was awesome like Mario 3 was
really awesome I mean two was the one I
absolutely love
Mike tries to punch out Double Joe with
those awesome games but
ah
I never been a big Nintendo guy man
and
I used to look you know I love I respect
and I respect Nintendo I did love them
with my child even though the first
Nintendo console I got was a Super
Nintendo
but as this was never a Nintendo guy man
I was more Sonic Sega Genesis guy man so
never actually played a Zelda game
before
I take that back I never played one in
in depth like sit down and literally
play it
I played uh I'm streaming Ocarina of
Time I'll probably start streaming again
tomorrow yeah
yeah yeah yeah
so you never played Ocarina of Time I'm
never I'm the only game the only game I
actually played
no 64 game no the only Zelda game I
played but it was really wasn't long at
all was uh the second one was it linked
to the Past like what was the second one
called on NES I don't know play that one
because my friend had it what's funny is
you know there's three timelines as
Zelda oh is it so how it goes is uh I'm
probably butchering some of the orders
but that's okay uh and don't worry guys
We're not gonna talk about that along I
just I I said I would talk a little bit
about it we'll get on to the smoke I
know you guys want the Activision thing
I give about 10 minutes here and then
we'll get on to that so how it goes in
the Zelda Timeline is Skyward Sword is
first that is establishing the origins
of the master sword like you were you
literally build the master sword in
Skyward Sword uh and then after that
you um I think there's a game between
but there might not be then it's Ocarina
of Time uh so at the end of Ocarina of
Time you defeat Ganon or you don't
defeat Ganon
uh so and then after that it breaks up
into three timelines
first timeline is you die
Gannon wins but he still gets sealed
away but you're dead
the second timeline is
you defeat Gannon but you return the
master sword so you go back in time
because in order for you to say pretty
much what happened since you didn't play
Ocarina of Time when you collect the
three jewels at the beginning and put
them in the the Temple of Time the the
tempo of time is pretty much like the
sacred realm they grab you and they hold
on to you for like seven years because
the because they deem that you're not
strong enough to take on Gannon right
and you grow up
in the in this realm and but when you
put the master sword back in the
pedestal you go back in time to when you
were a kid so pretty much that's the
second timeline that when you defeat
Ganon you put the sword back in the
pedestal and you went back in time and
you you never got the master sword and
then you got the third timeline and the
third timeline is you you didn't return
the master sword you continued on with
your life as an adult
because Zelda is pretty much like yo put
the sword back in we wasted seven years
of your life
put the sword back in and go live yo
with childhood so you know look we'll
keep this brief
I love the Zelda franchise I love it
it's one of my all-time favorite
franchises Zelda is definitely one of
the
the pedestals that I stand on as a gamer
but I wasn't 100 okay with how they did
breath of the wild now it looks like
tears of the Kingdom takes that breath
of the wild foundation and they expanded
on it and they brought the stuff that I
didn't like they left out like the
temples there's a lot of things that
wasn't in Zelda breath of the wild and
if it looks like they are bringing that
back and I hope they do man uh the
previews went up today looked very
promising
um you know we didn't really get into it
looked very promising but I hope man you
know maybe one day we'll get dirt to
play man we'll get dirt to play it all
right so
let me make sure I get these super chats
because you guys are super chatting like
crazy Final Super Chat from
Alvin I don't collect controllers but
redfall ones are fire and you can
customize them might swag snag too
this control is like crazy five dollars
to trap from Jade oh Jesus
shout out to all the Xbox analysts who
predicted that the great EB gay
acquisition they were you wrong as usual
fun times uh should we go over the stuff
that you're wrong about Jada
oh bro I got so many receipts man don't
worry about it five dollars to yourself
from gaming Forte Don't Put Me In The
Box dirt I love Xbox but I know quality
when I see it Zelda's going to Brick
records and any platform holder would
love to have it I agree
hey man I gotta come and visit you again
at that GameStop man
it's been about a year you visit a game
before today at a GameStop yeah he has
told me my PS5 last year
oh that's right gang gaming Forte real
dude man he was supposed to be a great
guy man he was supposed to be on the
show today yeah because when I he called
me and what's funny is J-Dawg called me
and I I just I just said the I'll talk
to you later but jado and I still ain't
called him but I was like I know what
he's gonna call me about well he's like
an hour after the the acquisition was
blocked it I wouldn't be surprised if I
looked at my voicemail right now if I
heard the j-dub laugh and then it just
hung up those guys are nervous they know
they were nervous they was nervous
they was nervous they had my notice when
they see out I woke up this morning like
what the f
uck I know they probably woke up like
what
you know what's up you know imagine if
they woke up
to um to them buying to the uh yeah
sometimes I wish that we could go I can
hit a button and just see just see it
just what would have happened if it
would have happened listen man all of
the PlayStation guys talking trash
that's cool but I mean you know that's
what they're gonna do because I know for
a fact if it was approved I would have
been talking trash so I'm not surprised
to see you know a lot of PlayStation
guys I haven't seen I'm telling those
guys I haven't seen in years on my
channel leave comments today
I'm like where you been at man I ain't
seen you in two years what's up oh dirty
this video didn't age well
no it's all good I'm expecting that you
know I'm expecting them to talk trash
but you know we'll see
yeah it's just one of those things man
you know we just gotta we gotta figure
stuff out you know let's go ahead and
get on to it man let's let's get on what
everyone's here hold up let me make sure
I got everyone's Super Chat all right
we've got a five dollar Super Chat from
drawing TJ pull out the UK and pay the
fines past the deal all right so we are
45 minutes into the podcast I see some
people still saying I mean
it's a chance that they don't go through
I mean I don't know we'll see we'll have
to see I I do I'm just kind of talking
about at this point yeah I do think
there is precautions that they can do to
still win this but I don't know if
they're willing to do that does that
make sense yeah all right
as some of you know ABK
Microsoft's been fighting for this thing
for a while like a tremendous amount of
time
and we thought it was never going to
happen uh we've been talking about this
for what a long time a year a year
what's funny is not the internet
originally
uh to see what are what are what's their
initials
CMA CMA was saying they didn't want it
and then there was rumors saying that
they changed their stance remember
and people generally was convinced
they're going to wake up to good news
this morning yeah like the good news and
we woke up
to them coming out there and you know
what I like what they did they went out
there and they tweeted them they're like
yo we blocked your [__] if you know why
we blocked your [__] because we think
you got a monopoly on cloud-based gaming
wow like there wasn't even no like just
Microsoft it's like the equivalent of
gangster they like we adding your stuff
you're gonna know we talking [__]
bro let me tell you the first thing I
saw I saw Florian Mueller he posted uh
activism Blazers stocks this drop I'm
like oh
he was like wow this is weird I was like
oh man then about five minutes later the
official news came out then I was like I
was getting ready for work was like Ugh
really because I'm gonna take all of my
bot homies they were talking trash last
night like yo I'ma sleep good tonight
I'm gonna wake up in the morning happy
in the exact opposite happened
I saw the homie Tim Dog was like yo this
is dope this is gonna be a great day
tomorrow a lot of the Xbox homies was
like that and we woke up like
yeah I woke up and uh IOP has like our
own little chat
woke up and saw that and first I was
gonna make a video but I was gonna wait
for Forte because we was originally
going to make like a like a duel video
um but he got stuck because he was going
to be on today's show uh oh yeah back to
my original story so I skipped JW's
message because I knew what he was going
to say I meant to call him back but I
never got to but it's okay that's not
part of the conversation and then Forte
calls me I'm like you know what Forte
ain't gonna I I'll pick up for Forte
yeah we talked about a couple minutes
and he was supposed to come on but he
got stuck at work so it is what it is
we'll get him on again five dollar Super
Chat from John TJ it's funny when they
say it would be bad
for cloud Microsoft gave 10-year Deals
they they they blind okay let's let's go
into that yeah they said they canceled
it because
of cloud infrastructure and yeah whether
or not
can compete competitors of cloud can
compete with Microsoft owning that
company do you agree with that no
no listen man everybody know they they
knew they couldn't really
block the deal because Xbox addressed
all of their console concerns so what
did they do they found a way to block
the deal they went to Cloud concerns
Cloud Market you know come on bro
plow what what is cloud at this moment
like you know they're they're betting on
what the cloud can be in the future like
you're blocking it because of that I
just don't I just don't get it you know
I really don't but you know I do feel a
little bit of their concern not enough
to cancel the deal because like if
you're able to let's say that Microsoft
does find that sweet spot to make Cloud
uh like Mobile gaming and streaming like
fill one to one and you have something
like Call of Duty on your side I do feel
like that is a huge that's a bazooka
like that's literally a bazooka you're
shooting people with bazooka uh but I
think we're so far along from that that
it's not realistic to think that is and
and if you look at something like I saw
people in the chat saying about the
10-year deal
I feel you guys they're offering 10-year
deals to anyone that would take it but
you know what's the problem with 10-year
deals dirt what's that they eventually
end so like no sure 10 years feels a
long time to us that's 10 years of our
life you know you've almost raised a kid
in 10 years but
10 years in business corporate business
it's not a lot of time
uh you know the people going in and out
of this corporate world when Bill Gates
retired from from Microsoft it didn't
stop the company it's still going
uh so I think that that is what their
bigger concern is and I don't it's not
like I agree with that 100 I can
understand it but I don't think that's
the reason it was canceled you know what
I'm saying I think this is one of those
things where it's like look lobbyist one
I think Jim is a genius
yeah I honestly feel like Jim went out
there and originally he was like you
know what I think I can get this thing
thrown out no not thrown out I think I
can get some good consolidations on this
we can get some good deals before they
buy them and then when when Jim started
seeing like
the Battleground after he started saying
stuff and people you know tossing and
twisting Jim's like
we can get this canceled we don't gotta
work with them we can get it called out
and I think that's that's why he did
what he did now let's talk about the CMA
um say right now I still think the Dell
can still go through uh yeah but there's
some there's some things that have to
happen the FTC have to approve
and the EU has to approve
yeah I think if they get those approved
they can use they can still move forward
with the acquisition and they can strong
arm the CMA to reconsider their their
decision
but the odds that the FTC and the EU
when we they both voice concerns
going through I would say is almost none
I I'm on the stance
that this deal is done it's debt what do
you think
well
um of course the bottom me I'm hoping is
not dead but I mean
I I guess I just want to sit here and
wait to see what happens
um you know because this whole year has
been crazy man we've been talking about
this ABK deal for a whole year
um you know everything you know like
there were times where things look just
as bad as today you know when the FTC
blocked
us or sued to block the deal that was a
bad day people was talking trash
PlayStation Fanboys was talking trash
Xbox gas was kind of down things got
better again than we're thinking the
deal is going to be approved again then
this happened so
there are a lot of things that happen um
that we obviously can't control I would
never be
so upset when when there's something I
can't control do we want it to go
through absolutely do I enjoy talking
trash yes I do but
um the deal
I'm still gonna uh have some hope
because you know we heard some people
saying that it's still possible
um if these things happen you know uh
you know the EU the FTC China
um needs to approve it also but you know
we'll see what happened but at the end
of the day all I can say this if it
doesn't happen if it's a done deal Xbox
is still going to acquire new Studios
and improve their brand they're still
doing okay for them not to really have
any games in 2022 No Game Pass still
grew a little bit Hardware you know
sales were down but everything else was
fine
Xbox is still fine you know without the
deal so here's the thing you know
people could talk all you want Xbox
they're not doing good right now uh
they're in a bad light
I for some reason I just have some some
bad feeling that right fall is not gonna
add anything to it I'm just hoping it's
just a middle ground and it doesn't make
it go down more I'm hoping redfall comes
out it's a solid experience that people
like it I don't expect a 90 Plus game
from uh from from redfall but I just
hope it's a good game
yeah I think it'd be a good game I'll
never think I mean I never thought
redfall was gonna like like be a console
seller
or anything like that but a quality game
I do believe it will be that
I think
that people will exaggerate when it
comes to this people assume just because
a company's in bad standings that it's
going to be like that forever
it's not the case
we've seen over and over again
corporations and console manufacturers
are able to rebuild their image but it
takes time
Microsoft did some bad step-ups and it
wasn't just the Xbox One reveal they
didn't nurture their own Studios during
the Xbox 360 error in the Xbox One era
they had a couple Studios but they
didn't build on to that they rely too
much on third party and first party
deals absolutely they did that was a
misstep too I would honestly say you
know not being the reason that they were
doing that they could have bought
BioWare Phil Spencer has came out
publicly and said that they had the
option to buy BioWare at one time and
they didn't do it because they had such
a good a good uh amount of
luck when it came to finding new IPS
they had uh bio Bioshock that used to be
XBox exclusive didn't it yeah it was
yeah the first one
then you have BioWare Xbox exclusives
um there's countless of them you got um
the the Stars Old Republic games you got
Oblivion they had really good thing and
that's why I will come out and I will
say this there is mismanaging in some
form
in Xbox I don't know where it's at I
don't uh but
you don't see this stuff like this
happen with Sony this much uh I think
part of the issues they expanded to too
fast
so I think there was trouble there at
the beginning communicating
but I think you're seeing now Domino
effects that wasn't addressed years ago
absolutely I don't know what they're
gonna do about it I don't I don't think
it's the end of the world stuff here's
the thing unless Microsoft goes in there
it closes Xbox's doors
What's it gonna take for for Xbox to be
back on track Dart yeah well okay let me
say this I agree with everything you
said um I say it all the time on my
channel
them not focusing on first party back in
the 360 generation or focusing on
assigning these second party deals or
third-party deals hell even Gears of War
was a third party deal you know like
Xbox didn't own on them until 2014.
those things hurt right over the years
and now Phil Spencer and those guys at
the point like yo we want to own
everything now I do agree with you they
had to they built they grew too quick
meaning they kind of had to because we
know we have 10 cent you know at the
time we thought Google was a player
Amazon some other companies were buying
um so Xbox said okay we need to hurry up
and buy before these other companies
back in financially compete with us like
a Google or Amazon
before they pick them up
Okay cool so they got zinni Max they
bought some other Studios they tried to
get ABK
um
Xbox is
Xbox isn't Flawless by any means yes
um I believe the Xbox one generation
hurt them so bad you know there's some
some people yeah bro I'm listening
real quick is people say just make games
games Take Time games take a lot of time
to make it's not just simple as just
pushing a switch they had bad image they
had bad Hardware they had uh
they had a lot of bad stuff bad software
issues it took years to fix this they
had multiple Lanes of bad PR in the Xbox
one generation that even Phil Spencer
addressed he said I'm gonna hit them
with Hardware first everything he's done
I would say he done good it's just these
games man that's the most important
thing
yeah I mean listen bro I agree to
everything you just said listen I say it
all the time the Xbox one generation
hurt Xbox so bad that it's been taking
years to recover
um the reason these games are taking so
long because they just didn't have much
in development in the Xbox uh one
generation after 2016 you know life
besides Halo gears enforcer and covet
her even more
and this is at the point now man
um I think the games are about to start
coming out this ABK deal seemed like a
huge distraction
um listen I want the deal to be over
with whether it goes through or or it
doesn't go through I'm just ready for it
to be over with so we can move on
without gaming lives right that's that's
the point I'm at right now
um so yeah I feel Xbox uh you know I
know guys in the chat of course they're
ponies no Xbox saying finally it's the
Xbox is fine they have a road map that's
actually better than PlayStations right
now with announce games if you want to
be honest they're going to be fine
um games pass is still growing and it's
been growing even without games last
year it still grew
um they made what 1 billion and a
quarter from Services I mean I don't
know I'm like people thought that's not
profit whatever they're they're they're
fine
right could they be better absolutely
could they fix the Xbox series X issue
right now yes they need to fix that
issue because I saw something
advertising Starfield
some and I I don't know on the bus in
some other country and they had Xbox
series s up there they definitely need
to fix the Xbox series X issue
but you know you're not going to hear me
doom and glooming like most people but
you know because I just can't ignore
the future you know I'm saying I can't
ignore what's happening what Xbox has
announced
just because you know his deal is not
going to go through that's that's when
I'll pull the plug you know
question and I'm saying right quick
El Nini
you lucky on this channel because you
know I cuss you are right
you're lucky I'm on this town to punk
all right hold up let me get these super
chats you got a five dollar secret from
El Nini regardless of what constantly
you support this is an L for consumers I
would agree with that I don't know what
you told uh dirt down the below but
we'll get to that in a second ten
dollars from Stitch if the you at the EU
says yes this is possibly where UK does
not see cloud gaming from Microsoft also
blocking this still now cuts off the
access for all other cloud service was
going to get ABK deals it's got a point
there all those places that was going to
get it from that deal got a two customer
care from Stitch uh AWS is the largest
cloud service in the world two dollar
super trap from drawn t uh TJ screw it
make 20-year deals I don't think the the
amount of years that was the issue at
that point five dollars from the thank
you therapist in the end Jim destroyed
Sony ABK relationship that's another
possible okay uh two dollars from bone
slave wait for E3 turned into weight for
games I'm tired I feel you on that but
see here's the thing all right so look
let's let's talk about the elephant in
the room yeah Xbox is there's probably
been the worst month for Xbox in the
longest time I would say probably since
I started bad news yes since I started
covering Xbox
this is probably the worst month I've
seen
since the Xbox One generator yes yes
that was that was a nuke this is a
couple missiles that was a nuke
um
I think the biggest issue that we're
having is just the lack of games and
it's like a question I asked who you are
like what's the thing that can get them
back on track games
rainfall comes out it's very fantastic
85 and above everyone's talking to
everyone's clamoring to it no one's
gonna talk about this Starfield comes
out an amazing game everyone loves
everyone's talking about No One's Gonna
talk about this hellblade you're
supposed to No One's Gonna talk about
this showcase good showcase showing
games that we're going to look forward
to showing his Fable gameplay showing us
the vowed gameplay showing his hellblade
gameplay now obviously all those don't
have to be there but showing us things
to look forward to no one's going to
talk about any of this that's why
regardless what happens with ABK though
which I don't care about this APK though
I'm gonna be worth you
I want it to be over with even if they
don't get it I don't care
um I would prefer to have been second
that's just me yeah because at least if
they would have got Sega the deal would
probably be done by now
right I
just want these games to be out if they
get that Fallout
that Elder Scrolls that
outer worlds too
that avowed the hellblade to
perfectly dark Perfect Dark uh you got
that um Hunter band Contraband if they
if these games come out and they do good
and people love them no one is going to
talk about the fact they don't have ABK
and that's if
last Super Chat talking about the the
relationship between ABK and Sony
it's done
I don't think they're gonna have a good
relationship with Sony to the end until
they change leadership
and that's not if people like Lulu
get promoted into the leadership right
10 super Trump from John TJ screw Sony I
hope they get popped by tencent or go
under it's sad ten thousand employees
are screwed and it said an American
company Can't Buy in another American
company I feel you
hey can I say this real quick yeah I
think that obviously like PlayStation
um is you know like Activision is still
going to work with playstates because
PlayStation makes them a lot of money
but but the relationship like the
relationship I wholeheartedly agree with
you bro I can see if this deal doesn't
go through in 2024 the marketing will go
back to Xbox because Xbox will pay for
it but the relent when you mess with
people money's at it addict will you
mess with people money
because you know Lulu Bobby coach they
are getting hell of a bonus it's
probably seven eight figure bonuses bro
they want to catch up with people oh
yeah is people sit there they don't
realize the the tension that's going to
be between Sony and Activision you know
when they have it's like I think I've
said this before but when you have a
conversation in the future and they come
together for this you know let's say
it's completely canceled Microsoft drops
out and they have these conversations
for the marketing for Call of Duty 2025
2024 and they sit down well how much
they could easily come down well I want
90 billion dollars do you got that Sony
because I could have had that if you
would have kept your mouth shut
yeah it's gonna be one of those things
it's like look
we're still gonna sell Call of Duty on
Playstation because we want that money
yeah of course but don't walk through
our front doors
um our marketing is Xboxes like
you saw how like Little's been talking
trash on Twitter for the last you know
six or seven months because they want
bro they want this deal to go through
but they they're still going to fight
this deal
Brad Smith said they're going to fight
it uh appealing so we'll see what
happens I don't know what the appeal is
going to do if they win the appeal what
does that mean I don't know bro I'm not
about to even act like I know
but um yeah but I'm just ready for games
like you said I'm ready for rarefall I'm
looking forward to it ready for force of
Motorsport already for Star field
no I'm just ready for it bro I think
it's one of those things where if this
I even if the deal doesn't go through
they can have all the bad publicity in
the world
until those games start coming out and
they're bad
I'm still with it because that's all I
care about I don't care about Call of
Duty I care about Fable I care about the
next iteration of Halo hope to God
that's fixed I care about a vow I care
about the outer worlds I care I don't
not the biggest fan of hellblade so I'll
probably stay away from that uh but you
that's the stuff I care about
and until those show me the quality look
you can sit there if you want to come
out and you say yo Xbox is trash they
haven't showed me no reason to get the
system I'm staying away I'm like 100
agree with you I get you I understand
why you feel that way and I understand
why you giving them that energy they
deserve that energy
but you can't ask me
an Xbox contractor that sit through all
this nonsense for years
[Music]
to abandoned ship
right before they start releasing the
games that they promised this in like
2018.
because P like there is it mirrors
people like there's certain especially
content creators
that really want you to have the
perception that these games are never
going to come out yeah Addie let me tell
you this that was some YouTubers I used
to love
they're still around but I used to love
their channels I'm not gonna say any
names on on online podcasts I I say
names on my channel and most people know
who I'm talking about
love I used to love their Channel I
remember in 2016 when they were like yo
PlayStation E3 was okay but those games
are far away they're far away and you
know what happened in a couple of years
those games came out and they were
Bankers quote unquote
those games were God of War uh
a Spider-Man Detroit become human those
games eventually came out and they were
great so for those people that think uh
these Xbox games yes they announced
these games in 2020 here it is 2023 some
of them haven't even come out yet those
games are coming out guys
they are and I believe Xbox believes
quality is is very necessary we want
quality we don't want the Crackdown
three era we don't want to say Decay two
era we don't want that anymore I
actually want quality I do want to make
a video eventually I think I'm going to
replay Crackdown 3 and make a video of
why I want Crackdown 4. Crackdown 3 was
good it's just I like the campaign first
off it was overhyped in areas that was
never going to realistically make
including the multiplayer and I feel
like that multiplayer was they they
promised they thought they could make a
different multiplayer than they actually
did and I felt like
by the time they realized that wasn't
realistic they already made it and they
spent so long trying to make it that
they neglected the campaign for
I thought the campaign was good though
no it was a good campaign but imagine
they would have took that whack
multiplayer and cut that and spent the
time they made that whack multiplayer on
the campaign that campaign would have
went from good to great yeah you know I
felt like the original Crackdown was fun
they needed more of that energy just in
a different way
[Music]
uh
hold up let me make sure they know Super
Chat up here yeah El Nini I'll read it
I'll read it el nimi with the 10.
addicts been facts about Xbox thank you
attic for being real and in touch with
reality you know what's funny here Dirt
has literally said everything I've said
ever said
but look this is the thing though
I I don't want a PlayStation guy giving
me any type of credit you know why
because that means I'm somehow bashed in
Xbox I saw somebody send me some of
them's like yo Dirk look at this I saw
y'all boy oh y'all y'all I'm lost Homie
Chris Hart giving Boomstick credit yeah
boom stick speaking facts as I never
want Chris hard to say that about me
because that means if he said I'm
speaking fast I'm bashing the Xbox
somehow so get out of here thank you
nene uh Nene whatever your name is
whatever your name is look I feel like
look we we do let the console Wars
people have their little fun in the chat
but just keep it respectful uh don't
come at people on some disrespectful
stuff because I'll get you up out of
here all right see what's funny is I
don't I don't need none of that energy
at all and I've just been to the point
with the console war stuff it's funny
and I might jump on like dirt's podcast
to like stretch that muscle a little bit
uh but it's just it comes and goes it
doesn't really matter to me more and you
know I feel like some of the people
uh viewers and uh content creators and
podcasters like they just let that stuff
go to their mind like sometimes I'd be
like I would be having like kids who
calm down
like it's not that serious
and sometimes like Kiss would be saying
the craziest stuff on Twitter and I'm
like why that's ammo for him bro they
love that that's ammunition for the
ponies yeah two dollar super shot from
rubber knob it ain't over to the large
ladybugs a t attack buys a tick
is that a joke
I guess he said it's not over to the fat
lady sings I guess I don't know what it
is in a different language maybe maybe
that's like a like a ground thing yeah
his currency was I think the A's
Australian I believe but when they speak
English so I don't know I don't know
what that means yeah look
I just want the industry to be better I
want Xbox to do better I want
PlayStation to stop taking advantage of
their their fan base I would love that I
want Nintendo to improve every aspect
that's not games you know what's funny
Nintendo got the games on lock but
everything around it sucks
let's just keep it a buck I'm sorry
Donna taku I know you in the chat and I
know that you you doing this right I
know you're gonna make him mad
I know you just swiping at the air right
now but guess what Donald
everything about the switch is below
average except for games
suffer because it
so you saying that Zelda is the tears of
the frame rate yes in the frame rate and
I'm not looking forward to that because
I'm playing let's see he'll fight you at
he'll fight you bro
you know what I'm six foot four Donald
talk I'm curious how how and you know I
have a background and presenting Jiu
Jitsu and I have a background uh in you
know multi so what what's your
background you know you're gonna he's
gonna fight me with like a Zelda hat or
like a link hat on and like a tuna and a
link little sword man and the shield
he's gonna he's gonna look like the
adult leak but have all the small uh the
the small leak weapons like the
boomerang hey you know I got something
positive about I got something positive
to say about Nintendo bro did you see
the Mario movie it was good it was
fantastic loved it bro it was fantastic
hey man uh Jack Black stole the show
that was fire bro I loved it hey check
out that I'm not even a Nintendo fan but
I went my daughter wanted to see it
fire it was great bro it was good it was
great
and that that should always be like
telling Dawn in the chat like man we
might joke around about Xbox and
Playstation but we like you know I don't
think I don't think Dirk cares but we we
understand Nintendo got it going on you
know they yeah the thing is Nintendo
does what Nintendo promises they never
do anything more they're like look
you know I'm sorry el Nina then I see
the Halo show yeah I watched it I
watched the end is entirely the whole
season
it was okay
it was horrible it was okay
addicts should go to the next Creator
look I'm big and I got a background and
stuff but I'm out of hell I'm out of
shape man I I would swing three punches
and be and be and be gasping for air man
okay you win
and especially see I I if I were to
because I used to do weight class and
stuff if I were I would probably go down
probably two weight classes I could I
could theoretically go down two weight
classes most likely one I can't do two
anymore I think I'm getting too old for
two uh probably be I could probably walk
in something like low 200s because I'm
like 285 pounds like yeah I'm a big dude
and yeah man
see maybe like mashed potatoes and gravy
man so it was wrong with y'all man
you're sitting there just just just
imagine like you know what they they
people clown on us but they wouldn't say
none of this stuff to her face
yeah none of us you know how tall is
Kane
not not Cog is kind of short because he
always seems short but yeah cog's
shorter I I would say cog's like
approaching the six foot area
it's six foot I don't know that never
asked how tall he is and Saul is about
the same height as is called it's called
yeah mashed potatoes and gravy you know
how it is you know we be eating good in
the neighborhood not not I actually
called us that I don't know if you heard
me say um you masturbate as I'm gravey
hey what's up man yeah I want those they
don't want no smoke with us
you know when it comes to the gaming
theme I just I just want the industry to
do better you know in Xbox I love that
company I do and you know you could say
what you want
that company May that company's the
reason I went to a couple e3s because
they invited me to it it's just like I
know that's probably some like bias
going on because I know a lot of
personal people in there but it's just
like
E3 is gone I don't know if it's ever
going to come back you know maybe it
will in the future
with a lot of big names behind it
but going to E3 when you're when I was
growing up and you know not having a lot
of money E3 was like a fairy tale you
know what I'm saying something I I look
forward to every year and I watch you
know because of Cognito uh you know
Corey black magic you know they
they helped me fund that first E3 trip
because I didn't really have the money
to be going like that you know what I'm
saying uh but they they they they they
they wanted me to go to it and you know
being in that that conference room
and hearing all the noise around you and
the Xbox theme stuff going around and
hearing the music and the atmosphere
there's nothing like it and I'll always
be biased towards Xbox because they let
me experience that
a couple times three times I gotta
experience that conference three times I
wish I could have experienced E3 bro and
people just don't realize like look like
PlayStation ain't never done stuff like
that I could never get an invite to
PlayStation conference we tried for for
a couple years we tried every year to go
to a Playstation conference because a
lot of them are like that Xbox is just a
little bit more flashy and I would
assume PlayStation is I don't know I
never went to it but um it's just I'm
biased I am and I and I won't I won't
hide that I'm definitely biased with
that kind of information yeah uh is
there any more than just Alvin because
we're about to close up here soon not
the album only one five dollar super
track from Alvin uh addicts and dirt
like The Dudley Boys in that like
wrestling yeah could destroy any pair of
content creators in the squad Circle get
the ladders and get the ladders yeah I
was a huge I still watch WWE now um it
was the tag team
um it was a white guy and a black guy
white kind of like yeah you know what's
funny and they both used to wear glasses
too it's so funny but I was telling Cog
when we were discussing who came with
the IOP name I was like we could we
could change the iron Lords podcast name
just said a joke and he's like well what
would you ever name it's like we could
name it quarter white cause I'm the only
white dude there
the quarter why that's a good one pour
the white that's funny at the end of the
day
it's like I told you guys I get it Xbox
is in a bad place
but they release good games all that's
going to be forgiven yeah PlayStation
had some of the worst PR in the PS3
error no one talks about it the Wii had
some of the worst the Nintendo had some
of the worst PR in the Wii U era no one
talks about it you know why no one talks
about it because they delivered games
and switched the narrative I agree with
you
I don't know what's going on with Xbox
in terms of some of the management at
some of the studios I feel like Phil
Spencer I don't think he's the problem
I'm gonna be real for you I don't think
Phil Spencer's the problem
but I am looking over there at other
people and I'm like what are you doing
what are you doing uh it's Phil
Spencer's fault for not
tightening that leash to make sure
everyone's doing what they supposed to
but as far as expensive huh I say like
my booty and Phil Spencer both of them
yeah because it's just like and then you
see stuff like Phil still going to
Studios like C thieves and stuff like
that it's like I thought that's Matt
Booty's job
but you never see Matt booty talking
about anything now I'm not saying Matt
but you don't do anything maybe Matt
booty just doesn't believe in social
media to that degree that's fine yeah
but he's like dude you in a a job where
you're working with the community you've
got to kind of be on social media at
that point it's like yeah I would say
it's it's not it's it's not an option at
that point like it's a social media
thing and I feel you guys I I feel look
the genuine people in the chat that
actually care about the about the Xbox
and proving I care about your opinion
but if you're in there just the clown
there's difference between having a
little joke
and letting it run your life and I think
some people have let that line go too
much to the left or right that's just my
opinion you got two dollars super trap
from Robert Kelly uh how many L's do you
think Xbox can take this is a big thing
more
hell but listen they'll take more
brother they're not perfect PlayStation
will take some males when you think they
don't take else yes they'll take some
more you know what's funny people say
about all
Xbox could theoretically take way more
hours than PlayStation ever could
Microsoft's backing Xbox they can
literally take L's from here until we
all die and they'll still be fine yeah
yeah two dollars for Jeff from txr one
one three eight th X seven countries
approved the EV uh the ebk merger I uh
one won't stop it one the one that
stopped at the big one though yeah I
think
um the ones that really matter is CMA EU
FTC and uh my boy post up said China is
another one that matters also yeah so
those four see the thing is like when
like the the their version of like Egypt
and stuff like Xbox has a lot to prove
down there and they have a lot to
improve so like even if they denied it
like there's like 20 people playing over
there there's not a lot of people
playing and obviously at only 20. I mean
there's a lot of people playing Xbox in
that region but it's not enough to
affect the overall thing I would say
that those seven a lot of those seven
could have denied it and as long as the
ones that haven't approved it approved
it they would be fine
when you got the big dogs
not approving it that's when there's
issues five dollars here from the angry
therapist not gonna lie which Expos came
out with a great custom series X I love
the controller but I want a console I'm
hoping I'm hoping you get that for
Starfield I think so I'll be definitely
think so I don't think they would have
did that for redfall yeah listen brother
I love Arcane I trust Arcane that's why
I still think the game will be in the
mid 80s
um those controllers are pretty awesome
though I know someone mentioned it
earlier those controllers are pretty
awesome man you can customize some of
them excuse me so that's great um you
know we're starting to see a little
advertisement now did you see the um
the subway in Sydney Australia that had
the like the red fault on the stairs and
the red fall on the wall in the subway
station did you see the Attic no I
didn't see that yeah I thought it was
pretty cool so I was trying to advertise
it a little bit there was just some
commercials I still think redfar is
going to be a good game man I'm going to
give it a try with the 30 fpsc what
happens I'm playing that on PC I'm gonna
be real with you yeah
all right so you know I think we're
gonna start closing this out guys you
know I I wish I could send us over to
someone
um but the problem is today huh fame
fame is off today yeah I'm pretty sure
fame's off today oh
I guess I'll send it over over this dude
because I don't know how many people is
in this chat but I want to make sure you
know we go
6 18 yeah let's just do it I don't care
all right so you know I appreciate it
for coming through you know you guys
came in through hard today almost 500
plus now obviously I know this is this
is a big occasion probably most of you
ain't coming back but you know I feel
you but one thing I just I just
appreciate the support two dollars super
trap from elenina thank you for the
stream addict yeah look man the ponies
wasn't too bad you just put in their
dirt I'm trying to disguage the
conversation you know what el Nina it
says dirt it doesn't say attic I'm
acknowledging the dirt place
I don't want ponies to acknowledge me
listen
um no like the ponies wasn't as bad as I
was expecting I was expecting uh
plethora of you know Albert G no Albert
G was actually respectful Nixon was
respectful El Nini they were all
respectful they wasn't like they see the
ponies yeah like the opponents are
blocked where they coming into I see the
problem the problem is
you've dealt with so many really really
toxic PlayStation fans that you don't
even deal with a little bit of toxic
anymore you just you've seen them all
one now
hey I listen if listen I think apple G
is blocked on my channel but he was he's
like respectful
um there's some of them that is coming
in bro just Xboxes trash y'all trash
y'all Bots block them I'm just now
getting my snipers to block them I'm
just now using it but look what my girl
got me for uh Valentine's Day oh look at
that man hey look at that dollar taco
look it's it's got my like year one
switch in it I still have a year one
switch like day one launch switch do you
still play it yeah I I'm playing
advanced war look there's tape on it is
that black tape yeah it's black tape on
it
uh the top is completely busted out as
you can see
hey buddy hey man the vent that was
right here is gone like and I'm pretty
sure one of these don't even hold it
anymore I had to replace this red one
like three times
so if you dropped it a few times or
something it doesn't take much
well see I have a year one this is from
2017.
so yeah I appreciate it for coming
through man uh you know you guys you
guys have been solid this week
definitely I've got a Super Chat man oh
two dollar Super Chat right right thank
you dirt thank you Ray Ray I appreciate
you man
all right Dart worth the people find you
at man span that in the chat I forgot to
put it hold on
um yeah guys uh I'm gonna probably do uh
like my one-man podcast tomorrow I I
would have done it today but obviously
you know we had an attic show today
um because you know I'm gonna give my
take about it you know listen man you
know you you start to calm down
throughout the day
and plus if you do it tomorrow you might
get some updates so yeah yeah so I'll
probably do it tomorrow we'll talk about
it we'll talk about how Xbox they're
still going to be fine if this deal
doesn't go through they're gonna
definitely get more Studios we know like
they were going to get more Studios if
the deal went through so I'm just ready
to tell you know we didn't talk about it
now that they were going to spend 90
billion on Activision if that doesn't go
through now I'm not going to be dumb and
say all of it's gonna go to to that but
don't be surprised if they start
dropping billions on Studios
and I'm here for that
I don't care for that so yeah so sub to
my channel guys you know I am an Xbox
entry Channel we do talk trash we have
fun I do talk trash about PlayStation
fan boys um you know lately I've been
talking about PlayStation
um but you know we do talk about Xbox
with Pro Xbox you know we're tired of
all the doom and glooms surrounding the
Xbox brand and um if you're Xbox fans
you're tied up you know the doom and
glooms around the Xbox brand you know it
we'll talk about it but we don't talk
about it excessively you know some guys
talk about it for a week at a time no we
talk about it we move on so
yeah the problem is is you know I've
always said people
will
say they'll criticize something on Xbox
but they don't realistically leave
enough time to fix anything you know I
only talk about something when it's
brought back up
I'll admit I'll go over a rant they need
to fix their gaming stuff but I give
them time to fix it unless something
comes up in the news that I need to talk
about it again there will be people that
have weekly podcasts about the same four
topics two dollars from the angry
therapist wbg TTS appreciate it man we
we thank you bro actually I'm gonna talk
to Cog we need all the lures need to go
over there on your show I would love it
bro I want to talk to Cog about that if
y'all want to get loose over there you
know y'all are welcome man okay
I don't know if Saul will be able to
make it because he always be working but
I'm pretty sure King and Colt could
probably make it yeah I love you man so
who Am you sucker
but I appreciate it for coming through
here I'm sending you guys over to uh to
frog uh you know go there and show them
some love tell them tell them IOP sent
you iron lore's podcast I don't know how
many people's in there but go over there
show them some love hit it get get a
like if you like his content stick
around sub to it uh but definitely go in
there and give them a like tell my
opcity I appreciate it for coming
through this is Lord addicts and Dirk
greggetty